[Music]
on this Sunday night state of emergency
in Alberta out of control wildfires
Force thousands to flee a siren is going
off it just seemed like a war zone What
It's Like on the ground during this
rapidly evolving emergency the crown and
colonialism for some people it is a
symbol of white supremacy the unsure
future for King Charles's commonwealth
countries
a new chapter in the fight for gender
Equity Men read books fine
men unless the woman is quite old like
me author Margaret Atwood 's attempt to
shake up
saying goodbye to Gordon Lightfoot how
his hometown is honoring the icon
global national
[Music]
good evening thanks for joining us
tonight we're going to begin with the
Wildfire situation in Alberta where a
province-wide state of emergency is now
in place nearly 25 000 people have been
forced from their homes right now 109
fires are burning across the province
and about a third of those fires are
classified as out of control nithu
garcha is in the Northern Alberta town
of high level not far from a cluster of
major fires and she joins us now with
the very latest
me too it looks quite windy where you
are so what is the latest
that's right the weather is changing a
fair bit and that's one of the biggest
challenges for fire Crews far I'm
standing in front of a donation center
here in high level as evacuees continue
to rely on firefighters who are battling
those flames and contending with
conditions like this as well as on the
kindness of strangers people have been
stepping up to support however they can
meanwhile the City of Calgary says it's
working with the province to open up a
Reception Center there tomorrow
this helicopter gets set to take off
Sunday from the high level Airport
a facility that's quickly become the
base for Crews continuing to contend
with difficult weather conditions and
fire activity as they fight a cluster of
out-of-control wildfires we're fighting
couples and residents say this is unlike
anything they
part of Northern
now this is the first time I've ever
been evacuated in 11 years her home
community of Rainbow Lake is among the
latest in a string of evacuation orders
across the region I feel as if I'm going
to come back to my home
um I think that we made the right choice
on evacuating our citizens high level
has become a Haven for hundreds Town
officials making room in a curling rink
beside an arena already full with
evacuees from Fox Lake the community is
filling up fast so we just don't have
the space with everything that's going
on right now we have been looking into
building a new facility that we'll be
able to host people as well as having
the cots and the blankets and everything
available for people would be very
beneficial to our whole region
especially with all of this unfolding
during a provincial election they hope
their calls to all levels of government
for help building that evacuation Center
will be acted on
Alberta state of emergency declared
Saturday gives the government power to
access emergency funds and mobilize more
support
as evacuation orders have continued to
roll in west of Edmonton this weekend
the Edmonton Expo Center has become a
Haven for evacuees from all over the
province including the town of Edson and
other parts of Yellowhead County
Parkland County and Drayton Valley it's
amazing what they had set up on such
short notice when we got here I was
really stressed because I was really
wanting to go home
and I hope our house is okay that
sentiment also being felt by many in the
town of Hinton Northeast of Jasper where
a box store parking lot has turned into
a campground for hundreds of residents
seeking Refuge during this already
unprecedented Wildfire season
now here in high level they estimate
some 1 000 evacuees are here from
multiple communities including Fox Lake
and Rainbow Lake and Alberta Wildfire
says more than 70 Wildland firefighters
are here from Quebec and Ontario and
they've been deployed to the areas where
they're needed most pharah
high level Alberta thanks for your
coverage and you do let's talk about
what's next now because slightly cooler
temperatures and even some rain showers
are providing a sliver of relief in the
Wildfire Zone we go now to Global
meteorologist Tiffany lizay she has a
look at what's going to happen in the
next few days what will it bring Tiffany
well pharah there is some relief but
it's short-lived so here's a look at
that Upper Ridge of high pressure that's
been sitting over Alberta throughout the
work week bringing those hot dry
conditions that has started to break
down a low pressure system and a front
starting to push in bringing some much
needed moisture to some fire prone areas
now the good news with that yes we need
the moisture the bad news is as this
Omega block starts to break down we are
seeing some instability we want the rain
we don't want those lightning strikes
because areas are so tender dry now
we'll continue to see some scattered
showers across Alberta throughout today
throughout tomorrow and even throughout
Tuesday we'll also see the southeasterly
float pushing that smoke up into the
Northwest the bad news as the week
progresses another sprawling Ridge of
high pressure will start to build and by
Mother's Day hot dry weather returns to
the province making conditions ripe once
again for wildfires across Alberta for
such a tall challenging situation there
global news meteorologist Tiffany Elise
thank you for that Tiffany
in Ukraine the leader of Russia's Wegner
mercenary group is signaling a U-turn in
his decision to withdraw troops from the
Ukrainian city of bakmut it has been the
location of some of the war's bloodiest
battles for months and the reversal
comes at a time of renewed concern about
the safety of Europe's largest nuclear
power plant Redmond Shannon reports
preparations in Moscow ahead of Victory
Day on Tuesday commemorating Soviet
sacrifice in the second world war
security is a high concern after the
Drone attack on the Kremlin this month
Moscow called it a Ukrainian attempt to
assassinate Vladimir Putin Kiev denies
any involvement the important holiday
was likely leverage for Wagner group
boss yevgeni pragosian
on Friday he posted a gruesome video of
the bodies of his mercenaries
threatening to withdraw Wagner from the
contested Ukrainian city of bakmut
unless Moscow supplies more arms many
called it an empty threat and so it has
proved
now says he's gotten those guarantees
his state his statements that he cares
about his troops and that's that's
basically not true this Canadian analyst
of Kremlin politics says it can be
difficult to know pregosian's true
motivations and just how great the rift
is with the Kremlin the more
intelligence resources are dedicated to
Goshen and his theatrics and drama with
the Russian Ministry of Defense shoigu
uh the less we're talking about other no
factors of what is going on further west
on the front lines there's a sense of
panic in areas near Europe's largest
nuclear power plant in southern Ukraine
Russia is now evacuating towns in the
region ahead of an anticipated Ukrainian
counter-offensive the un's atomic energy
agency boss says he is extremely
concerned about the situation adding
that all sides must act now to prevent
the threat of a severe nuclear accident
experts say multiple backup systems make
it unlike that damage to the site would
cause a meltdown but if it does happen
it could have faked a 20 to 40 kilometer
radius Redmond Shannon Global News
London
[Music]
explosions could be heard on the streets
of Khartoum Sudan today even as envoys
from the country's warned factions met
for peace talks since mid-april the
battle for control of the country has
left hundreds dead and it's forced more
than a hundred thousand people to flee
peace talks are being held in Saudi
Arabia and backed by the U.S and while
they're seen as the first serious
attempt to end the fighting both sides
have made it very clear they will only
discuss a humanitarian truce not
negotiate an end to the war
prime minister Justin Trudeau is now
back from King Charles's coronation
while he did some diplomatic business
while in London as David Akin reports
not even the Atlantic Ocean could
separate Trudeau from one of the most
pressing issues in Ottawa the alleged
plot by China to intimidate a
conservative MP
Saturday's coronation was the main bit
of business for prime minister Justin
Trudeau's two nights in London but it
was also a chance for Trudeau in UK
prime minister Rishi sunak to talk about
global affairs
a key file Russia's war against Ukraine
that will be a top topic when Trudeau
sunac and other G7 leaders meet in Japan
10 days from now so lots of
opportunities for us to make sure that
as we always are we're we're aligning in
our values and our approach to make sure
that the uh the impacts on on countries
around the world are are as positive as
possible next month the UK will host the
Ukraine reconstruction conference and
Canada expects to be a significant
participant in that initiative
on Sunday morning though truda was asked
about domestic matters why had his
government not yet expelled a Chinese
Diplomat that Canada's security
intelligence service identified as
playing a part in a plot two years ago
to intimidate conservative MP Michael
Chong and his family that two-year-old
plot came to light just last week
Trudeau said the delay was warranted
because Beijing might retaliate if
Canada expelled one of its diplomats
when things have pork when thinks of
canola one thinks of various various
real consequences that Canada and other
countries around the world have faced in
various situations if China's just going
to carry on with what it does anyway
speaking on the west block Chong said it
was absurd to Telegraph to China that
Beijing has leverage over Canada
unfortunately we got to this place
because the government previously hasn't
taken action to extel to expel diplomats
from authoritarian States like the PRC
or Russia who have engaged in coerce
serve and intimidation activities here
on Canadian soil this is a decision not
to be taken lightly and the foreign
minister is leaning into this very very
carefully and when will that decision be
taken the government has not yet said
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
the coronation and the lingering effects
of colonialism
coming up the country is cutting ties
with the crown and King Charles
eight people were killed Saturday in the
latest mass shooting in the United
States
the heavily armed gunmet opened fire
seemingly at random at a busy outlet
mall in Allen Texas just outside of
Dallas the gunman was killed by police
and seven other people are in hospital
there have been at least 198 mass
shootings in the U.S so far this year
and a new National poll done for Fox
News found that 80 percent of Americans
are in favor of stronger gun laws
and there is another tragedy that's
unfolding in Texas and this time it's in
the Border Town of Brownsville at least
seven people are dead and at least a
dozen more suffers injuries after they
were hit by an SUV that plowed into a
busy bus stop this morning
the bus stop located outside a shelter
that had been housing migrants the
driver has been arrested and charged
with reckless driving and police say
more charges are likely
to the United Kingdom now we're
following the extravagant coronation of
King Charles today celebrations were
more down to earth
no fancy invite needed for the big lunch
that's the British tradition that is
intended to bring neighbors together to
celebrate the crowning even as support
for the monarchy wanes Sharia Israel has
more on the debate raging in the UK and
abroad about the king's place in the
modern day
high tea a centuries-old tradition that
continues to this day
dainty China scones and biscuits
chocolate tart with hummingbird
chocolate it doesn't get more British
than this
but even in this Tea Room some of the
attitudes about the Royals are lukewarm
the whole issue of the monarchy is kind
of I'm indifferent or it could go away
and it wouldn't bother me welcome love
to have a look and choose these friends
are more definitive they want out with
the colonial aspect and the Imperial
aspect that it's just really outdated
now that it's Charles all of my
interests have just gone down the drain
there's indifference about the monarchy
even disdain and then there are
countries who want to break ties
entirely and that list of Nations is
growing 15 countries recognize King
Charles as head of state but six
Caribbean nations are considering
leaving the monarchy and following in
the footsteps of Barbados which became a
republic two years ago it is a symbol of
white privilege
um
for some people it is a symbol of white
supremacy Jamaica wants to do away with
that symbol it plans to leave the
monarchy by 2025 and is fighting for
slavery reparations from Britain as I
continue to deepen my own understanding
of slavery's enduring impact
for this professor of Caribbean history
the king's recent remarks fall
Charles
um was present at the ceremony
acknowledged the place of histories of
slavery in the country's decision but
couldn't bring himself to apologize in
Canada there are those who believe the
Royals are still relevant in an era
where there is more and more
dissatisfaction with politicians who are
sin as a source of
um division there is great uh advantage
in having this uh ceremonial figurehead
that is quite the opposite and is a
symbol of unity for others it's simpler
to keep the staff quo
[Music]
let's leave things as their
as they are tend to change things up a
debate about whether to toast or toss a
royal relationship
isri Global News Ottawa
[Music]
ahead Margaret Atwood on censorship and
the challenges to gender equality in
publishing
from Margaret Atwood to Toni Morrison
some of the most famous writers on the
planet are women yet in the world of
publishing women on average still earn
Less sell fewer books and when fewer
Awards than men a new literary prize
aims to change all of that our Jackson
prosco travel to Nashville to speak to
one of the famous voices backing it
this award goes to Fatima ashkar it took
11 years of planning to make this happen
this week Fatima ashgar was awarded the
first ever Carol Shield prize for
fiction the richest literary award for
women and non-binary writers I feel like
I'm not even like on
The Reel the 150 000 U.S prize is unique
and is backed by one of the most famous
women who ever put pen to paper this is
a huge prize and uh as as a veteran I
can tell you that prizes can kick-start
people's careers if people pay enough
attention to them on average women
Riders still make less money win fewer
Awards and see less promotion of their
books than men Atwood's International
success is the exception women read
books by men and women and men read
books by
men unless unless the woman is quite old
like me
or write sci-fi you know if you were to
give advice to young women who are just
starting out just beginning their
writing Journey what would you tell them
my aspirations lower expectations
so if you have low expectations you
don't get too dis disappointed if you
have high aspirations you you try your
best this award named for Pulitzer
prize-winning novelist Carol Shields
aims to help spread success before
runners-up are also given prizes other
emerging writers will be mentored so we
see this as fulfilling Carol Shields
idea of writing away the invisibility of
women's lives and supporting a woman
writer at every stage of her career it
comes at a fraught time for literature
especially in the United States books
are being banned from libraries and
schools for mentioning gender sexuality
and race Atwood's handmaid's tale is
among the most frequently pulled from
shelves in America she
urges Young Writers not to back down so
they worry about writing something
that's going to get them banned
um no
they should not
um
it's eventually not by those people but
there's it's it's it's it's across the
Spectrum you know trying to shut writers
down and and we've seen it in all
different kinds of regimes and we've
seen it throughout history
so nothing new
what is new is the support for the next
generation of authors with an award that
can help them defy the odds and write
their next chapter I really hope that
it'll mean that like folks can write
their own stories and write stories that
they really care about and and to know
that there's an authorship and there's a
readership for them Jackson prosco
Global News Nashville
[Music]
next Gordon Lightfoot icon and Hometown
hero Aurelia Ontario's fond farewell to
the folk music legend
[Music]
a Canadian music Legend's Hometown
gathered to say they're farewell today
Gordon Lightfoot who died Monday at the
age of 84 were turned one last time to
Aurelia Ontario where fans gathered to
pay their respects to one of this
country's greatest songwriters Global
Toronto's Alan Carter joins us from
Aurelia with more quite the crowd behind
you Alan
Farah mourners and well-wishers have
come out in the rain here in Aurelia for
an opportunity to pay their respects to
Canadian musical icon Gordon Lightfoot
Lightwood of course from Aurelia and he
attended this church as a child and even
sang Here
plays across the street from a church in
Aurelia
all my life
[Music]
mourners lined up to say farewell to the
musician who was born in this city 150
kilometers north of Toronto in 1938.
Lightfoot was respected internationally
but revered locally
the fact that he loved this city and it
really meant a lot to him and he's never
he never forgot his roots
[Music]
[Applause]
telling stories of Canada in song of
railroads and shipwrecks Lightfoot was
both musician and history teacher I had
to come and
send my prayers to Gord for all the
thing that he's done and opened up a lot
of stories of indigenous culture you
know to many people if Aurelia was his
hometown Massey Hall in Toronto was his
home away from home he performed there
more than 70 times he continued to
perform until he was no longer able to
telling his longtime bass player and
friend I think the last he repeated this
a few times but I think he said my my
life's work is done was probably I would
think the last one of the last things he
spoke it's that life's work lightfoot's
music that brought fans to this
visitation all the times listening to
him good times in bed yeah he's just
always been there he never forgot
aurario and you know we knew it so like
I say welcome back home gorgeous it's
where you belong today the bells at this
church chime 29 times just like the line
from Gordon lightfoot's famous song
commemorating the lives Lost In The
Wreck of the Edmund Fitzgerald and then
the Bell timed one final time for
Lightfoot himself
Alan Carter in Orillia Ontario thank you
Alan
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm foreign osser
[Music]
we're going to leave you with that song
the rack of the Edmund Fitzgerald one of
Gordon lightfoot's biggest hits and a
Canadian cultural Monument until
tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other
good night
[Music]
does anyone know
turn the minutes
[Music]
they put 15 more miles behind her